das war es also mit der entlastung und
die klima kläber von der letzten
generation die gehen damit suchen herr
estate wittern sie widerstand gegen das
klima versagen der regierung im verkehr
wir fahren ab morgen ohne ticket also
zeit für eine einfache sofortmaßnahme
sagen die für soziale gerechtigkeit
gegen den kollaps des klimas liebe
bundesregierung h soziale gerechtigkeit
also mit schwarzfahren übersetzt die
klimaaktivisten die sogenannten die
rufen hier also zu einer straftat auf
wir schauen jetzt direkt an die bahnhöfe
zu unserer bild reporterin kira ortmann
also ist das so dass jetzt ganz viele
deutsche an solchen ihren aufruf folgen
und heute nachdem das neue euro ticket
ausgelaufen ist einfach schwarzfahren
wir haben uns hier gerade schon am
bahnhof ein bisschen umgehört und die
meisten leute bzw alle mit denen wir
gesprochen haben haben natürlich ein
ticket natürlich würden das auch vor der
kamera sich die meisten leute zu geben
dass die schwarz fahren aber die
klimaaktivisten wollen natürlich
aufmerksamkeit erreichen und wollen
natürlich dass die leute mitmachen sie
wollen auch dass in die von dieser
aktion die menschen wissen und deswegen
würden sie wenn wir sie hier schon
getroffen hätten daneben das auch
zugeben aber die meisten leute mit denen
wir gesprochen haben waren ebenso
eingestellt dass sie gesagt haben nein
man muss schon jetzt auch solidarisch
sein und jetzt eben wieder sich ein
normales ticket kaufen wie jeder hier
und es wurde auch darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass während es nur ein euro
ticket ja schon sehr viel chaos an den
bahnhöfen war und einige personen haben
jetzt gerade gesagt mensch wir müssen
doch jetzt nicht noch mehr für chaos
sorgen und dann ist den
bahn-mitarbeitern irgendwie auch schwer
machen die dann ja eben wenn jetzt hier
jemand schwarz fahren würde mehr arbeit
hätten die polizei hatte mehr arbeit die
bahn mitarbeiter hätten wir arbeiten das
wurde hier schon kritisiert andere
menschen auf der anderen seite haben
dann aber auch gesagt ja es ist auch
richtig dass wir dagegen demonstrieren
gegen dieses ende des neuen euro ticket
denn es war einfach ein gutes ding viele
leute haben das genutzt und sie
wünschten würden sich wünschen dass es
eben jahr weitergeführt wird tiere
ordnen vielen herzlichen dank an den
hauptbahnhof hier in der hauptstadt
bisher sehen gott sei dank die leute ein
dass die aufforderung zum schwarzfahren
offenbar nicht der richtige weg ist um
für soziale gerechtigkeit zu sorgen
dieser aufruf der stand von der letzten
generation sie sorgen immer wieder für
wirbel mit ihren aktionen wer steckt
hinter der letzten generation
so kennt man sie sie kleben leimen
schrauben ihre händen der auf kreuzung
fest betonieren sie ein behindern damit
stundenlang den verkehr alles angeblich
um das klima zu retten weil ihn die
politik zu langsam vorgeht in diesem
jahr blockiert die radikale
aktionsgruppe bundesweit hunderte
straßen sorgt für lange staus hupen
wütende autofahrer sie pappen sich in
glasgow und london an berühmte gemälde
an die laken gruppe im vatikan museum
sie werfen in paris kuchen auf leonardo
da vincis mona lisa drehen will
pipelines ab gefährden die tour de
france sie suchen sie wollen die
aufmerksamkeit mit radikalen mitteln mit
ihren aktionen sehen sie sich moralisch
im recht das gesetz brechen sie dafür
bewusst doch wer steckt hinter dem klima
aktivisten sie nennen sich letzte
generation weil sie ihrer meinung nach
der letzten generation angehören die
noch verhindern könne dass die erde
unbewohnbar wird ziel des prozesses
aufmerksam machen auf die folgen des
klimawandels die politik zu zwingen sich
mehr für den klimaschutz zu engagieren
begründet
2021 aus teilnehmern des hungerstreiks
der letzten generation wie viele es sind
und einer taucht immer wieder auf
gründer henning jaske seine bekannteste
aktion 27 tage im hungerstreik
27 vierte stunden nichts mehr getrunken
mit der presse schlägt sich kammer
hinrichs rum 25 jahre alte jurastudentin
und pressesprecherin der aktionsgruppe
seit carla 12 ist engagiert sie sich
politisch unterbricht für die letzte
generation sogar ihr studium an der uni
bremen aber irgendwie müssen solche
aktionen noch finanziert werden dafür
ist margaret klein salomon zuständig sie
fördert mit ihrer stiftung allein in
diesem jahr 33 klima protest
organisationen weltweit mit rund drei
millionen us dollar
[Musik]
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit heiko
teggatz dem chef der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft und mit
unserem bild kolumnisten mit gunnar
schupelius schwimm guten morgen an sie
und an dich herr tigers zuerst einmal
die klimaaktivisten die immer radikaler
werden immer frecher werden noch frecher
die rufen heute zum ende des neuen euro
tickets zu einer straftat auf zum
schwarzfahren was machen sie mit denen
naja also ist zeigt auf jeden fall schon
mal deutlich wie sich diese gruppe mehr
und mehr radikalisiert also wer in
deutschland zu straftaten aufruf der
stifter zu straftaten an und wird nach
dem setzt auch gleich bestraft als würde
er selbst diese straftat begehen wichtig
ist nur ganz offensichtlich ist ja aus
der mazda vor klar geworden dass ich die
in deutschland lebenden menschen von
solchen klima chaoten was das
schwarzfahren angeht wenig beeindrucken
lassen das ist auch gut so
nichtsdestotrotz muss der staat wachsam
bleiben und der verfassungsschutz sich
diese organisation mal ganz genau
anschauen aber das gegenteil wird heute
passieren der tigers die werden irgendwo
schwarzfahren in irgend einer s-bahn
oder u-bahn natürlich sind nicht überall
kontrolleure die werden sie schön dabei
filmen und nachher können wir noch eine
zwei stunden warten dann ist das video
im netz und nichts passiert
ja also wie gesagt wenn die sich dabei
filmen und offen zugeben dass sie
schwarz gefahren sind dann wird sich
richtig bundespolizei die ermittlungen
dazu aufnehmen und schwarzfahren ist
eine straftat bleibt eine straftat ist
eine form des betruges und das wird
staatlich verfolgt
gunnar du hast auch einen besonderen
impuls bei diesem thema wir wollen dich
in dieses gespräch mit dazu holen denn
über dem grund schwebt immer dieses fast
unantastbare ziel es ist ja für den
guten zweck wir stehen für eine größere
sache ein und diese größere sache der
klimaschutz aber auch alle anderen dinge
für die sie sich einsetzen rechtfertigt
anscheinend für diese gruppe alles
rechtfertigt gewalt rechtfertigt
sachbeschädigung und rechtfertigt auch
dass man die gesundheit von menschen
aufs spiel setzt ja das wurde in dem in
dem beitrag eben ja schon ganz gut
angesprochen sie fühlen sich im recht
sie stellen sich über das gesetz und sie
fühlen sich moralisch auch dazu
berechtigt und das können sie ja gerne
machen das kann jeder in diesem land tun
muss dann muss er gesagt bekommen dass
das eben nicht erlaubt ist denn wenn das
jeder machen würde würde dieses land
zusammenbrechen und leider haben wir vom
gericht jetzt es gibt es erste urteil
den ersten urteilsspruch gegen einen der
klimaaktivisten nicht dieses signal
bekommen sondern ein ganz besonders
mildes urteil was in dieser hinsicht
irritierend wird ganz besonders mildes
urteil das war jetzt eben nach zwei
monaten nach seiner tat nachdem er sich
eben hier auf die straße geklebt hatte
das erste urteil gegen einen solchen
klima kleber hier in berlin wunder was
wär deiner meinung nach eine angemessene
strafe geben das kann ich nicht
beurteilen weil ich ja kein richter bin
aber ich habe beobachtet dass sozusagen
der moralische impetus vor gericht
durchaus eindruck gemacht hat dass sich
die richter haben beeindrucken lassen so
ist meine prozessbeobachtung ausgegangen
dass sie gesagt haben ja was die da
sagen ist richtig die haben ja hehre
ziele also müssen wir sie ein bisschen
sanft anfassen es ist ja auch vor dem
jugendgericht gewesen obwohl der täter
20 jahre alt war er hat sozialarbeit
bekommen und keine geldstrafe und ich
möchte gerne mal wissen ob das in einem
anderen fall bei einem so schweren
eingriff in den straßenverkehr auch so
ausgegangen wäre und man muss ja immer
wieder dazu sagen hier ist ganz schwerer
schaden angerichtet worden das können
wir gar nicht unbedingt ermessen wie
viele menschen im stau standen ihre
termine verpasst haben auch sehr sehr
wichtige termine verpasst haben was für
ein schaden der angerichtet wurde ist ja
gar nicht aufgerechnet worden und noch
mal dafür gibt es kein recht hat ehrgeiz
empfinden sie das auch so dass die
justiz aber vielleicht auch die polizei
nicht streng genug mit klimaaktivisten
umgeht weil immer im hintergrund ja
dieses große unna als partner als
unantastbare entschuldigungen ziel steht
wir setzen uns sehr für was gutes ein
also die polizei mit sicherheit nicht
die polizei hat eine klare aufgabe zur
gefahrenabwehr strafverfolgung die
ermittlungen zu führen entscheidend ist
wie justiz in dem fall die gerichte mit
diesen straftaten umgehen und in der tat
also 60 sozialstunden für die blockade
einer einer autobahn in berlin auch
verkehrs zeit halte ich auch für absolut
unangemessen und viel zu gering die in
solchen fällen ist es immer von vorteil
die strafe folgt sofort
jetzt ist kurz das bild stehen geblieben
bei heiko teggatz abschließend hier in
unserer runde nochmal unser bild
kolumnist gunnar schupelius sitzen nervt
das ja seit wochen seit monaten
millionen deutsche sind genervt von
diesem klima klebern von den immer
gleichen bildern und jetzt immer
radikaleren aktionen wie kriegen wir das
problem gelöst wie das legen wir die von
der straße das hat der vorredner in der
tat schon gesagt es kommt wirklich auf
die justiz an es kommt darauf an dass
hier ein riegel vorgeschoben wird wir
haben ja gesehen dass die klima kleber
wie wir sie nennen die das gericht als
bühne benutzt haben die freuen sich
schon auf die nächsten prozess war jener
prozess bringt ihm genauso wie eine
blockade wieder mehr öffentlichkeit das
heißt also wenn die richter sich nicht
entscheiden hier wirklich drastisch
vorzugehen und angemessen angemessen zu
entscheiden entsprechend dem schaden der
hier entstanden ist wenn sie das nicht
tun werden dann muss ich sagen sehe ich
da auch keine zukunft gunnar schupelius
willkommenes vielen herzlichen dank und
dank auch ich hoffe er kann diesen dank
noch höheren an heiko teggatz für die
diskussion über die klimaaktivisten die
immer radikaler werden
[Musik]